our live stream is up
so welcome to everyone on
linkedin and
get this session started my name is
stuart creek i'm with
simply learn
and i'm here with bill bailey a senior
instructor in cyber security
who is going to
conduct a cyber security master class
how to secure a fintech app
in a short time so
what i'd like to remind everyone
watching on
webex is that you can enter questions
for your bill into the q a panel
you can chat with us uh through the all
panelists feature on the chat button
and if you are watching on one of our
live streams on youtube or linkedin
t please feel free to put questions into
your chat
and we'll have those relayed to bill
and
i'm going to start with a quick poll
to get a feel for who's in our audience
today
so this is a
two-part question
and if you're watching on live stream i
apologize that uh but you can put
answers into the chat if you feel like
it
how much work experience do you have
how much time have you spent out in the
industry not necessarily in cyber
security but just in general
and secondly
we've been checking in with people all
during the pandemic how are you feeling
today um are you
doing okay or could you be doing a
little bit better um we know that surges
come and go and
the rules keep changing so
we like to check in to see how people
are holding up with that
and we'll give about five more seconds
and
here is the poll result
so bill as you can see
uh we have a
uh about 40 of our audience are people
who are still students
and then
about 30 are people with more than five
years of experience
the next largest group of people with
one to two years so
uh kind of a broad
range of folks in the audience today
let me introduce william bailey
20 plus years of experience in
information
security privacy risk management
served on chapter boards for different
associations that govern
cyber security and
he's a consultant
previously held the position of vp of
information security
for a financial institution so we're
extremely lucky to have him here today
welcome bill
and i'm going to
stop sharing my screen so that you can
go ahead and share yours and
you should have that control right now
welcome
you are unmute i'm sorry
i just unmuted you
oh you know that's why you know you can
never eliminate risk
right exactly i i wanted to uh i forgot
to warn you that when we go from our
practice session to live
um we
it mutes you automatically so here we go
that's okay i've heard worse you know
especially uh being in cyber security
when you're the security person in the
room
a lot of times there's management that
wants you to be quiet they want you to
keep it keep your
lips tied you know and don't say
anything uh and uh good to see got a lot
of uh good mix of folks here
um
and a lot of my life has actually been
spent as i was thinking about this how
do we
how do you how do you secure
your fintech apps
and not be the wet blanket in the room
and i i think it take you know it i and
i didn't want this to be oh well it's
this it's this miracle product
because it's it's not um but there there
are ways of doing it and you do have to
find a bit of balance sometimes and
think of it as a cycle really
that you get enough security
uh that you can move forward
get your product out to market
and then you can mature
your security over time and of course
you know in today's presentation i'm
going to talk about you know
what do i mean by securing your mobile
app i'm going to talk about that
maturity process uh and uh if we have
time at the end i have a little bit of
material on testing methodology which is
actually open source
um and that's i i'm a big fan of a lot
of times you know if you're doing
college courses university courses
you know
you don't have a big budget so you want
to turn to open resources
that are available to you you want to
get experience with them you want to try
them out
and you want to know what they are
because oftentimes these are the you
know these concepts
as i'm preparing this i'm looking at all
these different resources
and
nobody said the exact same thing
and so you'd have this one company over
here that offers these services and they
say do these things then you have
another company over here and they sell
products and they sell to do these
things
and then you're kind of trying to put
them all together
and going wait a minute well you know
oftentimes
security
is the enemy
of technology
and in fact every time i teach a cissp
class we talk about the reporting
structure and the isa csm class
um
you know the whole concept of the
security folks should not be reporting
directly into technology uh the reality
is often times they are
uh that the security folks do report
into a technology person and you know
technology is tasked with
turning the lights on making things go
and when we think about app development
uh if they want to get that product out
developers they they want to get that
product in people's hands there's a real
rush to market
and there's a desire to be first
uh and that's that's that we've got to
get that availability right out of the
gate we've got to you know and that's
why i picked this graphic here because
it made me think of you know that
sprinter who's taken off and they want
to get going really fast
uh and you know we oftentimes we hear of
you know like in standards years ago
with vhs and beta and with hd dvd which
some of you probably never you don't
even remember you know and the uh
blu-ray standard uh you know that that
rush to be first to market uh and we're
seeing it with some of our financial
services that we're seeing certain
financial services that are thriving
like i see some of the uh cryptocurrency
resellers that are still thriving some
are a little impaired and then you see
some of the other ones who are a little
late to the market they're struggling
right uh because oh well so-and-so
already does that so what you know
there's that i want to be first to the
market
but why does security come into play
well security comes into play because
you can do a lot of reputational harm to
yourself
and you could allow do a lot of
reputational harm to the industry as a
whole
and and that really it has a couple
effects the reputational harm people may
be less hesitant to come to business
with you as a result if you have a if
you have a fintech app and it gets
breached
uh there's going to be some reputational
harm uh and some companies are able to
fluff this off i'm always amazed you
know uh you know in the philadelphia
area wawa just uh just yesterday i
believe was eight billion dollars or
eight million dollar okay was just eight
million okay
um you know eight i get you know oh it
was just eight million dollars for that
little data breach we had in 2019 whoops
uh you know the targets the home depots
the capital ones you know but see i we
all know that though and i just said all
those names and you probably took a
split second and said oh yeah wait
capital one they had that issue
with the cloud-based storage and it
wasn't secured properly or you know i
could have said equifax and you would
have been oh yeah they they had the that
was the apache stretch vulnerability
that was out there for months and
uh so yeah there is reputational harm
because they they get fame but they get
the bad kind of fame you know and
sometimes it brings them down you know
and it's it's i mentioned those
companies they're like the they're the
outliers that can survive that kind of
fun reputational harm uh that prevents
them from being brought down
uh oftentimes when a company has some
sort of an incident or disaster if you
will a cyber breach or a cyber incident
it can bring them down
it definitely causes monetary harm
because
even if you have cyber liability
insurance
your premiums are going to go up the
next year
so it's going to cost you a financial
issue and as
in the course of fixing that breach
you're going to have to do a lot of
things real fast um and that's always
the awkward thing that uh i never wanted
to see a data breach and when you have a
regulator come in or an examiner come
into you
you know and i've you know i'm on
speaking terms with some of these
examiners i could pick up the phone and
call and we could chat about stuff
and you know i don't want them to come
in to me on a business visit per se uh i
like that conversation that we have
right now uh i meet them at an fsi set
conference or an hi set conference and
and that's the kind of relationship i
want to have with my examiners my
regulators uh you know i don't want them
to come in because of a breach i don't
want a third party coming in because of
a breach
because you start to lose control
and lots of things that you would take
your time
you can't anymore because now you're on
someone else's time uh and it's you know
it distracts from growing into business
if you have a breach and that's why
security fits into your fintech apps uh
because
you wanna make sure that you're gonna
have that mix of you know availability
that the application's out there
but you also have to keep in mind the
integrity
and the uh the integrity and the
confidentiality i almost thought like
one of the biggest things there right of
course you've got to have that
confidentiality here and i'm looking to
see
i i saw a little blip about a chat box
but i don't see the message here
so if i don't respond right away please
bear with me there
um and of course i know uh stewart is
watching the chat box and i trust that
uh if it's something uh crucial stuart
will jump in
okay great someone said please reply so
i just wanted to make sure
and i saw a blip but then i couldn't see
the actual message
so you know security fits uh because the
organization has a rush to the market
but there's going to be a lot of
reputational harm if that application is
compromised uh
what is it i i'm gonna i don't know if
it was fis or fi surf i have to go look
it up again um
brian krebs basically broke a a
notification app
or web functionality and it was like oh
boy
you know and and you know now it
distracts that company from doing what
they should be doing or what they had
already planned on doing
so uh now is there a magic bullet
no there's not uh there's not uh in
order to achieve the goals we have we
have to have a mix of people process and
technology and that's one of the biggest
thing i always make sure everyone
realizes that you can buy
a blinky box
and you can put it in your data center
and it will do whatever it was told to
do
now
the thing is though
we look at
the people and the processes to do the
care and feeding of the blinky box
right uh technology is often the first
choice it's an easy choice oh great let
me do this this should take care of it
but really what technology often does
is it can automate your processes and
there's a lot of products out there that
talk about automating your ci cd
pipelines and yes that's going to help
you get your product to market faster
and yes a lot of them do have security
hooks in them
right but you've got to make sure that
your people know what they're doing
because you can't always count on
technology to do a hundred percent of
this you know technology helps you
technology speeds you up technology
takes care of some of the mundane tasks
absolutely it does right uh but you know
when it comes right down to it we need
people
uh i see posts and they talk they show
the calculators and how the calculators
are miscalculating values
well okay is the logic of the one
calculator correct or is the logic of
the other calculator correct you know
and in fintech you know if you're
talking percentages of transaction fees
or commissions or things of that sort
yeah you need someone to actually look
at that you you can't always trust
technology all the time
and uh you know and one of the key
things is does the outcome meet
the business or the stakeholder needs
and i say stakeholder on purpose because
your fintech app who are your
stakeholders
right who are your customers they're
different who are your end users again
could be different
right uh you you think of financial
institutions right you've got folks that
are working in the retail uh bank or
branch or store whatever you want to
call it
and then you've got the end users who
are out
uh
anywhere right
uh performing your banking uh but now
you're seeing even technologies coming
in and they're changing the process
within a branch
so they they have less paper as an
example
it is a layered series of people
processes and technology uh and
you know
security should always be it should not
be bolted on
but it should be integrated and and
that's the thing where
security controls right technology
security controls great they're
wonderful for that you know people
in your processes
can also have security and i want to
make sure that's one of the first things
if you're securing a fintech app make
sure the processes and the people who
support that
also take consideration to security it's
really important
uh that technology doesn't cure
everything but you've still got someone
who has overrides as i sat in front of a
banker yesterday
and i heard them chime about oh you're
override expired oh no your override's
still good
that was a people issue the people could
circumvent the technology controls so
you know and even if you have a fintech
app you still have people you have
people at both ends you have people in
your organization that are the back you
know the back office support for that
fintech app and you've got the people
who are actually using the application
out in the field and so you've got to
make sure that there's a little bit of
security know-how in there
and that the the product or your fintech
app that your fintech app supports
the secure use of the application
and i i've seen some bad cases over the
years where you know they would say
things like oh you have to change your
password but
the system didn't actually check the
password
right and that's wow that's a big win
there
right
now your fintech app
it should be treated like a project and
you know i hear a lot of people they
talk about waterfall they talk about
agile
and scrum and these different project
methodologies well yes
your fintech app is a project or a
series of projects as you're rolling it
out absolutely and you know
you know
your team is going to do what they're
told in a project
and if they're a good project team
that's all they're going to do and you
hear me talk like you got to tell the
people you have to bake it into your
requirements for the project
it has to be part of it i remember one
system literally it was the password
check function
and i was the tester and i was a bit of
a smart aleck at the time i probably
still i'm a smart aleck
uh and they said okay so change your
password
and i my password is a and i change my
password to the letter a
and i said what's wrong with that
i said well wait it didn't actually
enforce a password
it didn't enforce any sort of complexity
it didn't even check anything
oh okay oh you know what that'll take
six months
what
that one little feature would take six
months to bake into a product this was
from a major manufacturer a major vendor
of software products
uh that they had not
for whatever reason they either it had
been in the industrial product and they
took it out which i've heard done
in the government contracting i've heard
people start taking features out oh you
don't need this so they take it out and
then it's
six months to a year to put it back in
and i'm not kidding six months to a year
plus six months to deploy it it gets
really long
um you know your project team should
only be doing what they're told they
shouldn't be doing anything extra uh
and because it can introduce
vulnerabilities and that's one of the
things is treat your fintech app like a
project keep it simple
substitute whatever you want for the
last s keep it simple right
specify what that project is going to do
and you know devops is the streamlining
of activities surrounding the i.t
solution development you know their dev
and your it operations
discipline devops is the streamlining of
i.t solution development and i t
operations activities
and along with supporting
security and data management so that's
why you know discipline devops or you
know we've also seen devsecops
which is development security and
operation uh to it uses automation but
it also uses culture
right and platform design for shared
responsibility
now in this slide here i try to pinpoint
a few things that really you know people
say well why do i have to worry about
project management you see number one
initiation of a project
what is the use case in your fintech app
who are your stakeholders right what are
the who are they
what are they doing with it what is it
replacing you know i you don't want to
have technology just for the sake of
technology
it there has to be a use case there has
to be a business reason to do it
um you know and that's that's where
we're starting to see we saw it with the
dot-com bubble two decades ago
and we're starting to see some of some i
i've seen a couple fintechs that have
crushed and burned um i i've seen two in
the last month that um yeah one has
decided to refocus their efforts
on a segment of the market that
they were perfectly fine for like the
last year and all of a sudden they're
like nope we can't do that anymore
and another one just
is pulling a plug literally uh pulling
the plug completely on their service
that they offered and they spent a lot
of money to get people on board
so
what's the use case right and what's the
scope and as you notice down in planning
what are
what are the product requirements what
are the security requirements
you know not just what what do the end
users what are the stakeholders what do
they need to see but what kind of
what kind of security features need to
be in there
what is the threat model what are the
risks
right you know because a lot of times
hey look i could do this cool thing on
my phone
okay that's great and i saw this with
healthcare hey look i could do this cool
i could take a picture off the machine
and the old machine still had all the
phi protected health information all
over that image and people thought it
was great it was great use case it was
saving people's lives but we were
sending it sensitive information via
unsecured networks
uh so of course like i said project you
you initiate uh you have the planning
phase uh when you're executing people
are doing what they're supposed to be
doing um and you have changes if you
find issues uh and of course if you want
a secure fintech app uh you do want to
have a little bit of maturity of your
processes and documentation is a big one
we're seeing a lot now um and and this
is and i say this now it is time now to
do documentation it is time now to do
that software bill of materials it is
time now to document your risk
assessment the reason i
it's
you spend some time now and do a level
of your threat assessment
because you don't if you do it after the
effect you're going to forget things if
you do it after the fact you may miss
requirements that require extensive
rework and you want to get this done
so you know
maybe i don't have to do a full-blown
risk assessment that looks at everything
else every single threat under the sun
but i should look at something yeah
maybe you know i i would look at like
mitre attack framework or i would look
at you know some of the other mobile uh
threats that are out there and real
quick get something in place on my
fintech app so at least i i've got
something you know uh because securing
it after the fact is definitely not the
way you want to go
uh and i spent a lot of time on this
because you know
you want to have consistent results
and if you force yourself to document
something in the cmmi capability
maturity model integration that was
really the characteristic of level three
right because initially you have heroics
you've got that star developer who does
something great for you they work in
overnight you know they work
all weekend you have a
team that works great you know that but
if they're not documenting what they're
doing you know they they some days
they're very good some days they're not
so good um yeah when we really
what happens here is the developers
develop this code
because this is now a fintech app on the
internet accessible from our mobile
devices our web browsers etc
anyone who wants to be a malicious actor
to perform a malicious transaction
they only have to get lucky once
and they have all the time in the world
because now you've put it in their hand
it's it's no longer confined to that you
know
10 to 4
branch mentality right
you know you don't physically go to the
location it's right there in the palm of
your hand
and you want to make sure the
organization should always have uh
policies procedures uh baselines and
guidelines because
remember i said that blinkybox that
technology if you don't have a policy
that dictates the use of that blinky box
or dictates that you have
to have a control in place
not specifically that box
but that you need to make security into
your development life cycle i've seen
this oh
the developer would tell me but you
didn't give me a security requirement uh
well you gave me a security requirement
but i checked the policy and it's not in
a policy
wow okay
and remember i say it takes longer to
add security in later so you know if you
want to secure that fintech make sure
your organization has some policies in
place and make sure you're giving your
your developers direction on what to do
uh so yeah that was all i want i won
it's a lot of make sure you've got your
policy in place make sure you've got
your governance in place make sure
you're thinking about the threat model
because that really then
colors and flavors everything else we're
doing here
so the
let's go ahead all right so secure code
uh you know there are features in your
integrated design environments that will
do basic um static
static application security testing
and there's a level of sas that comes
right in the ide and you don't have to
pay for it and then there's another
level that you could choose to pay for
it
and you know this could be a series of
improving your processes as you go like
i said yes you want to get your product
up out in the market right away
um
but uh yeah okay so you want to get your
product out there
you know take advantage of those that
you know ide integration that you have
and then look at the other solutions and
remember i said think about that risk
assessment because you're treating it
like a project
and then it makes it easy to decide oh
do i is is the static enough or is the
dynamic what i want or both well and
usually you want both but if you want to
get started quickly guess what start
with the first one
right and it's going to teach you
certain things it's going to teach you
developers things about how to write
code better
um you know obfuscate code don't make it
so obvious don't store variables so
they're easy to be found you can encrypt
sensitive code
people don't well why do i have to that
people reverse engineer software
and if they can reverse engineer it and
they could find sensitive code that
would no let's encrypt that
uh you know and repeat with each
iteration and you know as you build your
maturity in this process
now as far as like encrypting sensitive
data um
yeah there's sensitive data within the
application uh in a perfect world i
don't even put sensitive data on a
mobile device if i can help it i don't
put it in the app if i do it's in a
container that container is protected uh
you know
the uh md5 and sha-1 they're deprecated
uh
now you know subject to distribution in
different countries you look at aes
or you look at sha-256
for those uh hashes
restrict access to the container
uh like i mentioned a second ago um and
encrypted communications and this is one
i've seen over the years and people say
oh well i'm connecting to a gprs network
do i have to worry about encryption and
and believe it or not the body of
knowledge at that time said no
because the gprs was good enough
and
i'm sorry
no it's not
um don't trust don't count the cellular
network
so
data coming down right if it's sensitive
data it should be encrypted on the way
down
data going back out
yes it should have its own encryption on
its way back to your back office right
back to the the
the server that it's connecting to
the user can be anywhere
uh the user could be on a train and
it
it's always great the new york city
trains you you when you get to that
tunnel you see people turn their head
down
because they don't have access
you know all it takes is one person to
turn on a wireless hotspot and they're
intercepting your traffic
encrypt that sensitive data uh now if
possible um
don't have the data
right uh how much data do you really
need in your fintech app
and this is an easy one this is an easy
win uh you know if and i like with uh
property taxes yeah i need the parcel
number i need the amount paid maybe the
date paid
and that's really it i don't need the
social security number of that person i
don't need the date of birth i don't
need a whole lot of other information i
have definitely don't need the entire
history of it and what was it last year
there was that one state licensing
system that was sending everything down
and and the reporter
investigator hit f12
and it was obfuscated it was hidden but
they were able to basically to reverse
it
and they had a whole ton of pii on that
in their browser and it was already
there they didn't hack the back end it
was already delivered to them all they
did was hit f12 the developer function
so you know don't send it
down to the device
and don't put sensitive information in
the logs if you can help it
right what do you need a log do you need
everything
and that's an easy win right you want to
quickly secure an app if you don't need
it don't put it there don't put the data
down there if you don't need it
don't send it across that line
now with your developers they should be
using libraries
that are
current
up to date
uh you should check the libraries for
vulnerabilities
uh maintain a version history and this
is you know some of the classes we teach
you know uh itil they they have a term
they call it the definitive media
library
it's an authoritative source for all the
different api cpus all the different
libraries that you've used
and the versions and you can go back to
that place uh and if you
have a feature you put it in there you
need to roll it back uh how do you make
that application more secure oh i put
this in there it doesn't work let me
roll it back
um you know publishing requests all for
billing materials from others that
you're working with um
excuse me
you know do you have vlog4j without even
knowing it
i i and how many of us found that last
year we found
wait wait vmware has the word for jetty
yeah it was there
so it log4j is there you may not know it
uh and so and and that was not so we
found it was not secure and of course if
you have these in your fintech app you
need to update them
use only authorized apis uh if you cache
authorization credentials it makes it
easier during the development cycles
yes we like to make things easier for
our developers
however you know because it allows reuse
but the problem is
in the wild
it can be used by malicious actors
if they're if the apis are not
authorized properly
so that is one just to you know those
apis they should be locked in let's
require authentication authorization you
know authentication authorization right
they should be using encrypted means of
uh exchanging information
there's a big one
multi-factor one-time passwords and and
uh really just you know and and some of
this stuff you've probably seen this in
your own life
uh that you have these solutions uh you
know the passwords for an application uh
for your fintech app uh how long is the
password
and there's different people that argue
you know six characters eight characters
12 characters 14 16 etc
um
there's actually another term it's
called a pass phrase but that's kind of
hard to force
in an application
uh but you could do that through i said
at the last bullet point there security
awareness
you could actually some organizations
you have this fintech app
um as part of doing business with this
customer you could send them emails and
part of that email could be hey this is
how you create a secure password uh and
that that that's where you might suggest
a passphrase but within your fintech app
requiring a longer password
and um requiring uh character types
uh paying attention and i still see some
every so often that don't pay attention
to uppercase versus lowercase
and really what they're getting to the
brute force capability if someone could
just sit there and try username and
password combinations right
uh
you know and and so you can also assess
whether passwords are weak i i've seen
some financial institutions actually do
that
they'll run a process on the back end
and they'll assess whether that password
is weak or not or they'll do it when
you're changed when you're specifying it
in the fintech app you've got a little
bar and it goes from unacceptable to
strong
right and and you can't change your
password until you hit that a certain
level maybe that's strong maybe that'll
let you go moderate or maybe even weak
but
yeah they're starting to get you in the
right direction
uh passwords should be changed right
passwords get compromised
a lot of people tend to use the same
password over and over and over
and once that gets hacked one app gets
hacked
uh you know and somebody answers a
facebook survey and so you know
you want to rotate those passwords force
them to change them and remember the
passwords
you know i think i might uh suggest
apple is a good example of the if you
change your password on an apple system
you cannot use that password at least in
the apple environment
for a year i believe it is
so it's it's not just that hey you have
to change your password every so often
but once you change your password you
can't use that same password and not
just the number of times but a length of
time
so these are things to think about and
it's all based on the threat model that
introduce right i'm securing my
application based on the risks based on
the sensitivity of the information
that's in it and trying to find that
balance
biometric is a great one if you've got
access to a mobile device
but you have to keep in mind that not
everybody has
suitable biometric devices you know is
to you know do they have the fingerprint
reader do they have the retina scanner
uh how are you going to store that
information
and so biometric i proceed a little bit
with caution
because those of you in europe
gdpr
we're seeing some of the new laws in the
united states so biometric proceed with
caution
and make sure you're compliant
so i'm not saying turn it on i'm saying
make sure check with your legal folks to
see if it's kosher um for your customers
and figure out how you divvy that up and
remember i said product requirements
that yeah it's really
get it get that up front
um you get to use knowledge based
they're a good way of having a more
secure password uh in the application
um you know another trick there too with
knowledge based questions i mentioned
facebook and all those surveys that
people
make
answer
bogus answers
tell your customers to make up answers
that are not the real answer
right unless unless it's something like
if you have access to if you have access
to a like a lexus nexus or some sort
like a credit reporting service um yeah
where you could actually check based on
public records then fine knowledge based
questions
can work
but keep in mind they're not perfect
because sometimes
knowledge based questions
someone else has access to those public
records also
so um but you know cell phone email
you know verification
you've tried to log in
you know someone tries to log in it's
gonna it's gonna send a text message
it's gonna send an email it could send
an email to say hey someone logged in
from the new device
right um and you can also use that um
you know for like certain functions
within the application that's a nice way
of you know you say okay maybe i don't
have a really strong password
but if you go to change like a transfer
outbound
in a financial services app
uh hey wait a minute what are you doing
here i'm gonna prompt you
for a secondary form of authentication
that's a really great way to secure that
fintech out because someone gets a
username and password you know they're
going to try to connect to an external
bank they're going to tr or an external
institution they're going to try to send
those funds out
so
that's a good place to put that
secondary trigger in place there um
and uh and you could have other criteria
again requirements
uh when you think about your threat
model you know uh if someone goes to
change their password you know maybe
they can't do certain functions for a
period of time too
uh you're fit into that cap uh if you
take a look at the system
take a look at the mobile application
yeah can it see if uh what is it you
know if we are jailbroken or rooted
right the apple devices jailbreaking
because we want to break free of the
apple jail um or androids we root them
you know sometimes we root them because
we want to get like tethering
capabilities uh we we want to run
development utilities we think it's cool
we get access to a secondary application
store
but the minute you've done that that
you're
any jailbroken or rooted device
it it then compromises your application
and so that's something that you could
do to make your app more secure is to
look for that
and if you see a jailbroken or rooted
device if you see any sort of like a
keyboard interference
that would be one to look for if you see
that you're
in a sandbox or emulation
uh if you have an old version of the
android or ios operating system why oh
because you know the jailbreaks and the
roots they don't work on the new release
they work on the old releases so uh
there are vulnerabilities and at a
certain point vendors stop supporting
the android or the ios or that old phone
you know here in the united states uh
you know lg phones there are very few lg
phones sold this is not a key market for
lg anymore in the united states
is that something do you want to only
support certain types of android certain
versions of android certain versions of
ios
you know
your application could
maybe do a quick check to see if it sees
other malware that's present on that on
that device these are things that help
secure your app by seeing that you're in
a clean healthy secure environment in
the first place
now the application itself uh leaves
privilege
and
a theme here minimalizing the what the
app does
uh you know
consider what functionality should be on
the mobile device versus the web browser
and think about if like if someone wants
to change an account or open an account
is that functionality you want to have
um do you want to support that are you
going to require additional secondary
authentication
limit the ability to screen capture
earlier we talked about sensitive
information here least privilege do you
need the full account number or do you
just need to see the last four of the
account number redact information that
doesn't have to be seen because it's a
convenience to see the account number
and to see the last four digits and
maybe don't put it on the first screen
make some you know a way of securing
your app may be that you put that
functionality a couple layers down
uh session handling uh tokens uh instead
of a device identifier because that
device identifier is going to be the
same basically until it takes an os
upgrade uh os update oh it's patch um so
use a token and you can expire those
tokens
they should always be stored securely on
the device
and they should not have predictable
sequences that's one of the key things
that you know if you use a predictable
url or predictable token
we've seen you know wireless uh the
wired
equivalent privacy was broken years ago
because it was very predictable
yes they they used the you know the the
unique value but it was very easy to
predict that series and very easy to
compromise that
uh and test periodically um
you know you're testing your app uh
you know and periodically you should go
back and re-look at those tests because
vulnerabilities change
today tomorrow six months from now
and revisit your threat models
because the new uses of technology
increased processor power
the availability of those emulators
that you know earlier weren't as readily
available now i can get them they have
faster processors
review that risk assessment review any
server side logs for activity that's
something it's uh
and that's more of a detective control
than a preventive control
i always want to prevent prevent
something from happening if i can but a
detective control can be advantageous uh
there's a slight
concern that you do need to look at
those logs periodically
um
if you just store them that does nobody
any good
but you could do that there are
platforms that you can use to do that
log correlation
and to
identify
possibly fraudulent activity um and
that's where your your security of your
app you know
even if the app starts to do something
part of your process could be to delay
that until there's a chance to review it
uh and so someone keys in a transfer but
it has to be reviewed and it could be
subject to audit it could be something
that's logged and that you know you
could have automated triggers off those
logs
uh review any customer queries or
reports uh customers that are contacting
you reporting any sort of an issue with
the application reports of issues you
know and looking to see what the
root cause analysis was
what was the root cause of that problem
that that customer had and
yeah
you test you have changes for your
application
uh expire old versions of the
application
most fintech apps are starting to do
this now you know at a certain point in
time on the back end it'll expire that
app
so it can no longer function and just
plain
you know stop the application from
functioning
unless it can connect to the backend
server
use consistent testing methods and
criteria
uh you know consistency is a big part of
security
if you don't use a consistent testing
methodology
at least be able to justify your
rationale
well we did it a different way and
here's why
okay so it's documented you have that
understanding of why
now one example that i wanted to
share with you
and again this is open source oh wasp
right uh
owasp uh you may know them uh for the
the web applications but they have
specific testing for mobile devices
and so you know as far as something i
could leave you with right here in this
session i definitely look at the
resources that oast has available i mean
the things i've told you about
you'll actually find those in oas quite
often but most what i told you is out
there maybe a few of the cyber security
things aren't there because os is a
little bit more technical in nature
but with this mobile appsec verification
standard
they define a mobile app security model
and and then in the mobile security
testing guide they actually give you
test cases
they actually give you documentation you
can download from the os website
and um
you see you you have a checklist of your
rep you have your requirements and and
your test cases that you're able to go
out and test you know and in this case
you know is sensitive data written to
the application logs it shouldn't but
that would be something you could test
and they give you as a very good manual
that's out there right on the os website
so that is one tool i'm not selling the
tool it's it's a uh it's right out there
on the off os website
yeah
so yeah i know we always want to leave a
bit of time at the end for compressions
and answers
so
uh you know
our summary uh you know fintech apps uh
even even when it's in an agile project
should build security in not bolt on
yeah you've waterfalled agile you know
agile is a series of very small cycles
very short cycles
it should still have a requirements
consideration you know yes you're only
going to go for a certain period of time
you're only going to do a certain number
of features but the security
requirements of those features should be
in there or
prototyped in at least you know in
development sometimes you'll prototype
it
so at least you've got that placeholder
that you know you're going to come back
and do it and i think i recently
actually saw it with a with a streaming
application it was funny it even said to
do
literally the error message was to do
and it was the logging feature and that
was the update they just recently did
was they actually corrected that error
but they knew they had to put it in
there
and so it wasn't really bolted on it was
we left space for it
and we know we're gonna invoke that
error
and as they got to it you know they put
they actually populated that error
checking functionality
security involves people process and
technology
it's not just the technology problem if
you want to get this done quickly you
have to include the people and the
processes you have to include
you have to include the stakeholders you
know the end users the customers the
business units and you have to think
about what they're going to do
with the application the right way
you also have to think about what are
they going to try to do
for fun
right
uh applications have to offer
adequate availability
but they also have to address
confidentiality and i actually should
say integrity there my apologies
um
integrity of the data the integrity of
the data as it comes down to the mobile
app integrity is the data that goes back
up you know from your fintech app your
mobile app up to your your service you
know you want to have that
confidentiality and integrity uh in that
uh transmission in that transaction uh
because these are becoming matters of
financial record in fintech uh you know
just like years ago in healthcare yes i
i have to you know the diagnosis is
important
uh and getting the exact codes and
everything is is important
and what secured today may not be secure
tomorrow and so you should test
periodically and revisit the sdlc
and just make sure that your teams you
know your your development teams should
be baking security or
it should be baked in uh and it should
be part of their project plan right from
the start that's why i put that project
initiation right up front because if you
don't put those these security tasks
in your project plan if you don't have
policies that tell them to do it it
won't get done or if it does get done
it's going to be inconsistent and all it
takes
is one entry point
now let me see what we have over here in
the chat window stewart
let's see how do i get that and yeah i'm
gonna go ahead and take back the uh
screen sharing we'll go ahead and do the
q a
because i do have
a number of questions that are
coming
from
uh
chat and q a and
we have one from
daniel marquez on youtube
who is asking um
he's been working for about 35 years so
he's at the age of 49 now which means
he's been working since he was a
teenager
and
he's looking to switch careers what
advice would you give somebody who might
be considering cyber security as a
career switch
cyber security is a career switch um
well it's i guess the question
how far away from technology are you
because if you're already in
like if you're in development
programming you can switch to security
if you're already in infrastructure you
can transition into security
um
as far as
if you're totally new to security
hopefully you enjoy working with
computers at home
and you sort of build up your skills a
little bit and uh then see where you can
maybe manage a technical project i think
that's sometimes is an avenue for folks
ismalia has a similar question um
she'd like to understand something
she says i'd like to understand
something basic if you're planning to
study cyber security as a profession for
securing network infrastructure
and apps like fintech do you have to
have a programming background or do you
need to understand learn programming
uh if you are you need to
learn the basic language of the
developers
and interact with the developers
and i think one of the biggest things is
that whole communication
with the developers so you don't
necessarily have to know how to code
um but you need to have that partnership
and you can both be sitting at that
table collaborating
and ask i i always say i ask a lot of
dumb questions
yeah
asking dumb questions is the way we
learn because then we get smart
um
goona asks because we're going to be
sending to people who are on the
webex live session here we do send out a
proof of attendance certificate for
webinars like this
uh as long as you've been here for at
least 30 minutes out of the out of the
hour
but guna asks if a certificate or proof
of attendance for something like this is
useful um
to show to an employer that type of
thing
uh yes it can be um i don't know if you
have to show the certificate all the
time
but the fact that you have it if they
ask
i
and as far as being certified myself uh
sometimes i'll just say okay i attend
like i see squared i attended this event
and i
attended this event they don't ask for
the actual certificate
but i have it just in case they ask
and there's of course
um
a whole series we will talk a little bit
about uh the cyber security
certification programs simply learn
offers
um that give you more formal training
that
you can demonstrate
um
jiva asked an end user
question about how you would tell if
your mobile has been hacked or not
i'm chuckling because uh i there was
just a a
a little brouhaha that was going back
and forth of yeah visit these websites
and now run this um
oh what is it was it a citizen's lab
type of tool
and i was like well yeah you just
visited the website it just told you you
visited a compromise website
um
what did that prove
um how do you tell if your if your
system has been hacked
um
it's you know just like a standard comp
like standard desktop uh laptop computer
you start seeing strange activity um
you can um
you know if it's on a wi-fi network well
wireless at home you can look at the
data throughput that's happening and if
you start seeing peaks that you're not
doing anything on the device
um that's a good sign
uh yeah if you're not sure
i
sometimes the easiest bet is can you
restore from backup and everybody should
be able to restore their contacts from
backup you should be able to restore
your apps and if you're even thinking
that it might be infected
i might just go ahead and wipe it and
start over
yeah um
you talk about test frequency
is there a best practice or is this
going to vary from case to case
well i think you know and part of this
concept of doing it quickly is your
cadence or frequency is going to be
based on
the time and resources that you have
um
meg has a question about the possible
future we might be living in
we have heard in
different press
outlets and
news stories how
quantum computers will be able to defeat
any of our current
encryption schemes
being able to
compute so quickly and so
so on such a vast scale that they can
overwhelm any
number of bits we might put into a
encryption key
is that true
it
it it yes it is and and there's actually
uh there's a there's a working group
that's working on
new forms of cryptography that will be
more immune
to quantum computing because of the sure
cycles that quantum computing will offer
yeah i mean it's just the
the the theory behind
long encryption keys is it's just
impractical to solve it it's not that
it's impossible but it's impractical but
when you have
uh you know essentially infinite
computing power in seconds
it becomes practical so
um
and pranal just made a comment post
quantum cryptography
um
let's see
gladys follows up on your advice about
uh a um
end user securing a mobile device
um
every time she tries to download her
mobile banking app it tells her that the
phone is jailbroken and rooted and is
is there anything she can do to to
recover from that
um
well
it depends on the jailbroke jailbreaker
root that was performed
but that's that situation where you wipe
it back to factory defaults
and then the mobile and that's a good
fintech app it's doing exactly one of
the things you're supposed to do is if
you detect malicious activity
do not
allow the application to function
and so i don't know if it's a she said
jailbreak uh jailbreak that's apple um i
believe there's a way to go back through
itunes well it was itunes i'd have to
look at it now you can go back and
basically wipe the phone clean and start
over
okay
um
we have several questions about the
roadmap to becoming a cyber security
expert and what types of
courses and
programs
one might consider for that
you have some advice on that
uh well i know myself years ago
i started with the comptia
a plus network plus security plus
i started just it was something i
enjoyed and then it slowly became my my
passion uh and if you're jumping into
cyber security the security plus is a
great certification
i've seen a couple other folks in the
chat window they talk about uh their
developer tracks and you know simply
learn has developer tracks if you want
to code
you want to be on the coding side of
things there are whole tracks for that
um the
um as far as if you want to be on the
grc governance risk and compliance
there's like the cissp the cism if you
want to be that hacker type of mentality
there's that ceh uh like security plus
is oftentimes that entry into like
general security
roles
okay
um
trudeau asks a question
and
they're two questions one is
she's seen security uh testing
done once or twice
only at the end just before product
release
is that enough or does testing have to
happen
more regularly during
production and post-production
well i think sort of where the question
is going is
with the development life cycle you can
do unit testing
and you can test that unit by itself and
then you do the integration of the
various units
if you can do small tests that's a way
of quickly securing your app because you
get an early insight
into the vulnerabilities
and
the other question she had was
what precautions should an end user take
when they're using a fintech app what
what what
can the user do to help protect
themselves
use unique
passwords
and that's where i talked about the the
strong passwords
and to to use those features when
they're supported by the fintech app
and don't answer those facebook polls
asking you what's your favorite color
what's your dog's name where do you want
to go on vacation
uh i've had fun with some of those i
i had like whole themes and i would just
on a sheet of note paper i would make up
fictitious answers
so i'm like i'm garfield and my favorite
food is lasagna
and my favorite pet is odie
but i don't really have a cat named
dodie or cat named garfield
right if you're if you're not familiar
with garfield
it's a cartoon cat that eats lasagna and
torments his uh
his owner's dog odie so
um
and
let's see
so
on that point aaron asks how do you keep
track of all the different passwords
you're going to have when you have
unique passwords across
multiple applications and you're
rotating them
changing
time time
spreadsheet is cheap
uh as long as you've got a password on
your computer
and
there are password keepers or password
managers that you can opt into
and
because we've got a number of other
questions i'm running out of time but
let me say
can we connect with link on linkedin
with mr william
pretty easy to find
okay and i'm actually going to drop into
the chat right now
um
that linkedin
address so that you
connect with them
as well as reminding everyone that we
will be sending out a follow on email
with a link to this recording
and i'll
include the link to um
uh oh us in the um
the wasp in the
email so that you have that as a
reminder
um
and
i think
i'm looking through i want to see if
there's anything else that jumps out
okay i'm going to ask
go ahead a question asked about do i do
i address the front end or the back end
part
you would look at that vulnerability and
ask yourself is this something that can
be addressed easily at the at the mobile
device if yes great um
and that's where that back end is that
detective type of control
um
so
and you look and see what the effort is
it i hate to say it depends it depends
what the level of effort is and
sometimes i may pick the not desk
solution just so i can get it done now
um
you know as far as and i've referred to
oauth because oasp is an organization
that has a ton of resources that are
totally free
and the other last question i'm going to
ask is
is there
really a difference what makes
securing fintech apps different or
distinct from securing
any other type of
app that's out there or any other type
of
domain
well actually i think you heard me
mention healthcare on purpose
healthcare apps
deal with phi
uh fintech apps we're seeing very
pervasive because you're not in the
healthcare space uh you're using a
fintech app as part of your daily life
and so i think that's why we're seeing
the pervasiveness of your online banking
you know you're doing you're investing
you're doing your cryptocurrency
you know you're doing your payments um
so there's that whole gamut of uses that
it just the the use is so much better
but the things and in the u.s we see a
lot of financial laws
um and health care is not as robust it's
getting there
um
but the same
same ideas would apply and that's why
i'd use the term sensitive on purpose
because you could actually take what
i've talked about and think of your
industry or you know your industry
sector what's sensitive to you
and then handle it the same way
there's also the aspect of you know
there's a famous figure in us history in
the 20th century was a bank robber named
willie sutton
and the story about him is that after he
was arrested
a newspaper reporter said mr sutton why
do you rob banks and his answer is very
simple he said because that's where the
money is
so one of the reasons why
securing fintech is is such a vital
thing is because that's where all of our
money is and
there's a huge payoff if a breach is
successful so
with that i'm going to go ahead and
we'll move on to the very final part of
our presentation
and i'm going to mention some programs
in cyber security that simply learn
offers
um
there
we have a number of individual courses
for
certification as a certified ethical
hacker or comp tia certification that
type of thing
um we also have
comprehensive programs that put multiple
courses together
to take you
to the level of becoming a
cyber security practitioner
the comprehensive curriculums that have
an industry-aligned learning path that's
based on what people are looking to hire
in the industry
these have integrated labs they have
hands-on projects
that
you do
through your browser you don't need to
acquire a specialized software
but they give you the ability to
practice these
techniques and tools hands-on
live virtual classrooms with instructors
like billy who
meet with you a couple times a week to
go over the class assignments and and
show you how the work is done and then
you have
your own
time to do homework anytime 24 7 during
the rest of the week
to to complete the rest of the course
and prepare for the next class meeting
so
these are great programs
they're very flexible they're very
affordable
and i'm going to show you one as an
example that we offer in the united
states but there's a number of other
ones and i will share a link with you to
that
category page so here's the the uci
university of california irvine
um
program
the cyber security bootcamp and
this is
a program that
we
provide the the infrastructure for we
work with uci they help develop the
curriculum
one of their
faculty overseas this program
and it comes up step by step
like a staircase from the orientation
session
uh through enterprise
enterprise infrastructure security
application and web application security
then looking at ransomware malware
ethical hacking techniques and finally a
capstone project
in which you're given an industry type
problem that needs a solution that draws
on all of these other
steps in the process
which you then
turn in
it gets created it's something that you
can keep in your portfolio and show to
future employers and say this is the
caliber of work that i do
so
we're very proud to offer those things
i do want to ask a question
whether this is a type of program or
type of courses that people in our
audience today are interested in so i'll
give you about the
30 seconds to answer that
and also if you're
interested in when would you start
is it something that you want to do
right away or is it something that
you're
looking to plan out into the future
we always say that if if it's something
that's going to affect your life and
your career positively
the best time to start is right away so
not to influence your answer
but i'll give you another 10 seconds
three
two
one
here we go
90 88 of the audience is interested in a
program with this type of thing
and
almost a third are interested in
starting right away so
what i will do right now as we're
thanking bill
into the chat i'm going to put
a link to the page where you can find
out more about these programs
and
i want to thank bill for being here
today i
appreciate you going through this
topic with us
and giving us
the tools and understanding that that we
need
to approach that problem and solve the
problem securing fintech apps
and as i mentioned his linkedin
information is in the chat i'll put it
one more time
yeah thank you for having me
okay
and
the last thing i'll mention is that we
do have another learn it live for those
of you who are
interested in digital marketing as a
skill
or
if you have friends who are
please do
consider coming to this learn it live
which will talk about how to build
customer personas
personas are the
kind of theoretical people
bill described building a cuts persona
to
mess around with facebook
um
polls
and creating a
a
theoretical individual who
is a cat who likes lasagna and has a
friend named odie but
when you're doing a digital marketing
campaign you want to do the same kind of
thing and think about
what would a typical customer look like
and what are the variety of different
typical customers that you might
that might use your product or service
and you want to learn how to create
those personas and create
messaging journeys nurturing journeys
for each of those so this is an
important skill for digital marketers
and i recommend that you come to it
bernadette is a fantastic instructor as
well
so
with that i'm going to go ahead
and
let me say make sure that i've
okay i want to thank everybody for being
here i want to invite you to to join us
on our
social media channels at simply learn on
facebook on
twitter
and
simply learn on linkedin and with that
we conclude our webinar so thank you all
for being here today